let's talk a little bit about florida we
have i mean i guess i would sort of call
this good news out of florida in the
sense that in politics you often get
reverse consequences so like think back
to the 2016 republican primary which
really started in 2015. donald trump
arrived with no experience
um
no uh reasonable ideas
no credible path to getting anything
done
and um he was rewarded
by uh becoming the republican nominee
and ultimately president of the united
states and similarly we have seen in the
state of florida
radical
covid governor ron desantis experience
the covet hellscape that florida has
become and not really suffer when it
comes to polling and when it comes to
approval that seems now to have changed
and that is very good news ron
desantis's poll numbers have started to
plummet
as the coveted numbers in florida
continue to get worse and worse and
worse and what impact this will have
on his gubernatorial reelection campaign
and possibly his eventual candidacy for
the republican uh presidential
nomination we just don't know but let's
look at this report from truthout
florida governor ron desantis is seeing
approval ratings plunge after enacting
and seeking to enforce stringent
measures to prevent schools in florida
from taking actions to prevent the
spread of coronavirus earlier this year
desantis signed a bill into law that
banned local governments including
school districts from issuing rules
about masking despite a cdc
recommendation that every school require
masking to prevent students and staff
from contracting and spreading covet 19
after several school districts said they
would keep their masking rules in place
desantis threatened to withhold the pay
of district officials and punishment for
their defiance even though they were
acting in the interest of public health
desantis went forward with the threats
despite polling in a state showing that
most people support policies made at the
local level to keep masking in place in
fact most americans back masking
requirements in schools and florida is
no different around 62 percent of
florida voters support rules requiring
masks for students and staff
now new polling shows desantis may have
harmed himself politically over his
stubborn stance on masking a political
matrix listener group survey asked
florida residents where they whether
they have a positive or negative view of
the governor on his handling over of the
pandemic only 43 say favorable 53 almost
54 percent say unfavorable importantly
this puts desantis at a disadvantage
against his potential political
opponents he's up for re-election in 22.
in a hypothetical matchup against u.s
congressman charlie crist desantis would
lose the governorship 43-57
and desantis is also polling
faring poorly against the florida
agriculture commissioner nikki freed
freed would win about 54 to 46. we have
this new polling data it is very
interesting to look at this is the poll
that's referred to
and we'll go through some of the numbers
first when rating the handling of the
pandemic desantis has 54 percent either
unfavorable or very unfavorable
when you break it out by party lines
republicans are still strongly
supportive 62 66.2 percent have a
combined favorable and very favorable
the poll goes on to find next we see a
complete flip from eight weeks ago with
today charlie crist leading desantis
57-43
what seems to be the biggest part
is the amount of grasp each has within
their party with democrats christ has
almost 90 percent of his base with
republicans desantis is down to only 75
percent of republican responders so
that's an important signal and that's
similar actually to what we saw uh with
donald trump where you saw
uh joe biden
going into the 2020 election carrying
almost every democrat whereas donald
trump was still carrying a majority but
a smaller majority of republicans and of
course we know how that ultimately
turned out so you know this really
shouldn't be news like this is what we
call logical when people's opinion
reflects and responds to what takes
place in the real world
that's logical and that makes sense
we've become so used to seeing
republicans reward the worst people and
the worst political performance that in
a way were sort of like surprise wow
desantis has ruined florida over covid
and his approval rating is plummeting it
makes sense but it still surprises us
now someone wrote to me and said you
know what's going on david
ron desantis supporters are dying of
covid so he's losing approval
that's the math doesn't check out on
that for now but it could
over time you could actually start to
see the fact that it's
disproportionately republicans who were
dying of the virus because it's
disproportionately the unvaccinated who
are dying of the virus it could start to
make a difference and what i mean by
that is as of about 10 days ago
1500 vaccinated people have died of
coveted nationally and meanwhile a
thousand people a day are dying so total
1500 vaccinated but every day a thousand
are dying overwhelmingly the
unvaccinated over time
you could see a state like florida where
ron desantis only won by 33 000 but it
now has 42 000 coveted deaths it's
conceivable you could get to a point
where the death partisan gap
could cost ron desantis re-election
a lot more people would have to die
because remember not everybody votes so
of the 42 000 that died
probably about half or actual voters
maybe even less and then within that you
have to look at the partisan split it
might only be a seven or eight thousand
dollar sorry seven or eight thousand
death gap between parties so
very rough estimate unless you see a
hundred and twenty thousand a hundred
and forty thousand dead in florida
uh with a big partisan gap i don't know
that it would actually lead to desantis
losing because his voters died but the
fact that we're even talking about how
far are we from that math making sense
tells you how insane the situation has
become in florida if you're in florida
let me know what the mood is there let
me know what 2022 is looking like that's
a big if democrats were able
to hold california in the recall
and take florida in 2022 it would be a
really big deal
um heading into 2024. let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
dpakman science has shown us that
lowering your body temperature at night
helps you sleep i can't sleep in a hot
room that's why i love our sponsor
chilly sleep which makes customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions to
sleep better their flagship products are
the uhler sleep system and the cube
sleep system which is what i have both
are hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video